première vaccination pour cette
algérienne membre du personnel médical
elle est prioritaire pour bénéficier
d'une dose de spoutnik v les membres du
personnel médical sont en première ligne
pour combattre le virus
il est donc logique qu'ils soient les
premiers à recevoir le vaccin
ce samedi les premières doses ont
également bénéficié aux personnes
atteintes de maladies chroniques et aux
personnes âgées
un soulagement pour cette habitante de
blida
cette ville située au sud ouest de la
capitale a été le premier foyer de kovy
19 en algérie c'est mon fils qui m'a
parlé de la vaccination et j'en ai été
très heureuse alors je suis venu aussi
vite que j'ai pu au moins ça nous
permettra d'avoir un peu de repos et
d'arrêter d'être stressé de devoir nous
montrer si prudent toute la journée
que dieu nous protège de ce fléau
je suis jeune je n'ai pas de maladies
chroniques et je suis venu pour donner
l'exemple aux jeunes de la région et aux
algériens en général pour qu'il n'ait
pas peur et qu'ils puissent être
vaccinés dès ce dimanche
la campagne de vaccination s'étend au
personnel de sécurité aux agents de la
protection civile aux enseignants ou
encore aux imams alger doit aussi
réceptionner un premier lot du vaccin
britannique d'astrazeneca et oxford pour
faire face à la pandémie
quelques 8000 centres de santé sont
mobilisés à travers le pays où près de
trente gouvernorats sont soumis à un
couvre-feu partiel selon le dernier
bilan officiel
le nombre de contaminations aux kovy 19
approche officiellement des cent sept
mille cas avec environ 2900 essai